[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommaire box marine petit le
boxeur de la team farrugia et donc on
n'a pas réussi à conquérir la ceinture
de champion d'europe
le sportif s'est inclinée ce week-end
face aux belges francesco patera nous le
recevrons dans quelques instants dans
cette émission rugby dans le championnat
de fédérale 2 plaisir a réalisé le plus
bel exploit de sa saison les plaisirs
aux à la lutte pour le maintien se sont
imposés à domicile contre drancy une
victoire acquise sur le fil dans une
ambiance électrique qui pourrait compter
à la fin de la saison résumé du match à
suivre
cyclisme sur piste ce mercredi à 13
février la sélection pour les prochains
championnats du monde en pologne fin
février a été dévoilée au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
coup de projecteur sur cette équipe de
france son reportage d'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par de la boxe marie
petit a échoué dans sa quête européenne
le boxeur de la team farrugia ils
encourent sept incliné aux points face
aux belges francesco papa terra qui
boxait à domicile pour nous parler de ce
combat nous recevons sur ce plateau
marvin petit deux jours après son combat
et son coach temps guy farrugia
bonsoir fort marvin est ce que vous avez
réussi à récupérer après cette défaite
c'est dur c'est très dur de récupérer
après un vol comme ça c'est très dur de
récupérer c'est sûr travailler quoi vous
avez récupérer psychologiquement donc
pas encore tout à fait franchement je
sais qu'ils y pensez quoi c'est que j'ai
que ça dans ma tête
la limite demain on me d'eurofins combat
je leur fais quoi vous voit pas trop
marqué physiquement par contre non j'ai
pas tgp a été marqué j'ai pas été marqué
j'ai pris un coup de tête ici en dessous
c'est tout j'ai non j'ai pas été marqués
va pas toucher 1
il m'a pas touché beaucoup de fois
c'était beaucoup d'échos amateurs qui
est chrétien mais beaucoup de cook est
passé en dessous des esquives re temps
il faro geste il faut aider marvin
psychologiquement après une défaite
comme celle-là est ce que c'est votre
rôle aussi oui il va partir en vacances
cédant à faire le point après les
vacances je rentre c'est mieux c'est pas
facile parce que le but est aujourd'hui
d'or de reclasser et merville n'habite
les deux
la de retrouver des combats de
préparation tout ça et c'est plus c'est
plus à une fois qu'il a un but il va se
retourner vers son match aller tout seul
vince un battant il va là il va rebondir
encore plus fort qu'il détecte c'est une
grosse déception
pas une grosse déception parce qu'il a
une alors sur le combat sur la décision
du combat c'est une grosse déception sur
la préparation qu'il a eu avec des
coupures qui elle a eu le poids qu'il a
eu à perdre et cetera et cetera
s'il est à 100 % mais l'adversaire et
finissait pas voilà ça je peux vous dire
du groupe voilà je m'attendais que ce
soit pire il a il a fini les gaz un
composant de ses moyens et c'est clair
que à 100%
l'adversaire il fait quoi en 4,4
secondes maximum
voilà mervyn vous êtes d'accord avec
votre coach je suis l'époque je suis la
grille avec moi mais moi je sais je
n'étais pas à 100% non plus qu'est ce
que vous avez vu comme problème dans
votre préparation celui-ci familiales
j'ai perdu deux membres de la famille en
dix jours d'intervalle
tu d'autres soucis encore donc ça va ça
m'a tourné la tête je suis en
construction d'une maison j'essayais
trop de trucs qui m'a pige à démontrer
l'amour quoi donc c'était beaucoup de
trucs qui va qui me prenait la tête et
donc après moi je suis content qu'on me
dicte au guichet un maton et
jusqu'à la mort j'ai acheté un camp
tanguy dit que vous étiez à 50% vos
capacités vous êtes d'accord avec avec
les oui je suis d'accord avec lui parce
que mes mois niveau solo ring je sais
que j'aurais pu faire deux fois deux
fois plus appuyé par deux fois plus et
j'ai pas digéré un peu il ya des moments
gérer parce que je me dis voilà il ya
deux rouges
et voila quoi mais franchement j'ai fait
le combat j'ai fait le combat j'ai pas
lâcher j'ai fait comme moi du début
jusqu'à la fin c'est moi qui ai tanguy
et mustapha bouzid m'ont dit de garder
le centre
j'ai gardé le centre sur listes au
milieu c'est moi qui a fait commence à
manquer avancer les coups les plus nets
c'est moins que les amis parce qu'on en
pro mais pendant amateur
donc j'aimerais j'ai mis des coups les
plus nets c'est moi qui a qui avaient
combattu et qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence
du coup dans ce combat finalement
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence c'est
qu'il est chez lui la différence il est
qu' on était chez lui à domicile
et voila quoi il avait il avait un
entraîneur il y avait aussi le siège de
liège à liège c'est le pays qui est là
bas donc favoris donc on est chez lui
quoi que vous êtes d'accord ça à jouer
forcément le fait que que patera ce soit
à domicile tout à fait moi j'ai regardé
le combat je sais pas combien de fois
voilà j'ai quant à la fin du combat avec
marvin j'y monte à 1 petit point
d'avancé
t'es chez lui faut pas désespérer
tu vois je regarde le combat après soit
5,6 points pour marvin parce que moi
j'ai toujours mes boxeurs perdu naquit
voyais toujours leur boxeur devenu moi
j'ai toujours mes boxeurs pessimiste
voilà et comme on appelle ça et voilà je
vais après je rejoue à 5 6 points pour
marvin
effectivement il ya quelque chose là
quelque chose de vraiment tu vas pas
quoi on va vraiment il ya des choses à
faire
voilà normalement normalement voilà on a
on a conclu que qui devait qui doit
rebondir assez vite pour le championnat
d'europe
normalement c'est pas normal et
normalement et en plus il faut préciser
aussi que ce combat était conclu
actuellement le meilleur championnat
d'europe de l'année où on n'est qu'au
mois de février
toutes catégories confondues c'est quand
même un petit exploit
donc c'est quand même un combat qui
était intense olivier au niveau
technique au niveau web niveau technique
on regarde regarde les commandes entier
loties tape sur les gants ou une tape
dans le vent et les marvin qui met des
coups les plus précis les coûts les
coups puissants les coûts je sais pas ce
qu'il faut je ne sais pas vraiment ce
qu'il faut exactement pour pour comment
pouvoir vraiment il a fallu que le
coucher quoi je sais pas je ne sais pas
il ya un moyen de contester peut-être
l'arbitrage on va essayer
voilà on va essayer on va faire appel il
ya des années quand il ya des trucs qui
sont en train de se passer
voilà maintenant entre nous sa méthode
la décision est donnée revient non pas
sur des décisions mais ils peuvent dire
le combat est à refaire
voilà et s'ils veulent pas en faire le
combat ils lâchent la ceinture et marque
une envie ni les challenges heures ça
peut être une solution
mardi c'est une autre solution
j'aimerais refaire c'est trop mangé avec
lui même d'ici deux mois ça serait top
mais là je repars à 100% la neige lui
montrer que c'est pas le vrai champion
d'europe quoi et comment ça se passe un
appel
justement il faut mais je crois je vais
prendre à la fédération je vais prendre
un avocat je vais prendre un avocat je
pense vu prendre la roue cas je vais
payer même qui était payé 1000 euros je
vais payer 1000 euros de ma poche mais
au moins je vais je vais me débarquer
parce que l'aja mais j'ai pris un avocat
mais la peau ce combat là je suis obligé
et vous êtes moulin combattre dès demain
ouais
dès demain oui je sais si demain on me
proposait combattent à gré je leur fais
chauffer des plus tôt en france tandis
franchement oui
franchement oui mais après après le
problème qui nous manque ça c'est encore
une fois c'est des partenaires on a
besoin de partenaires on a besoin d'être
soutenu on a un niveau le plus gros
chantier cdk sémard vide
on a aussi gallus au championnat france
les numéros de français
tamaryn tôt les kékés challenger au
titre national tu as on a une finaliste
au championnat consommateurs on a un
club qui suit il faudrait peut-être
qu'on se réveille un petit peu qu'il ya
des partenaires qui commence à me dire
ça serait sympa ça serait sympa de faire
un peu plus loin moi j'ai envie de
changer de suivre quand on est dans le
haut niveau quoi le message est passé au
niveau de la ville d'elancourt
dernière question quels sont vos
prochains objectifs marvin ça serait une
revanche tout de suite où vous voulez
faire un combat intermédiaire dans les
prochains mois mais si c'est possible
dorénavant je te fiche de la forêt moi
je suis ouvert à tout esprit beaucoup
visite alors si demain tu es and might
and soul mais en face de moi je cherche
un nom gérer j'irai droit drogba quoi je
suis un boxeur je sais pas je suis pas
t'en sors tu
je suis là pour provoquer on est on est
pas pourquoi
merci marine petit merci tandis
farruggia on espère vous voir rebondir
très rapidement sur les rings et
pourquoi pas une revanche pour un titre
de champion d'europe en tout cas on vous
le souhaite et que vous reveniez avec la
ceinture ici à venir avec y'a pas de
souci ça moi cette ceinture déjà la base
je vais laisser la place de faire ce ce
titre qu'il a été chargé d'or c'est moi
qui lui ai dit la place parce que je
sais de vêtements qui devait ce combat
du coup les récupérer
merci mr une punition continuera
évidemment à suivre votre carrière avec
attention sur tv 78 on continue à part
du rugby dans le championnat de fédérale
2 à plaisir a sans doute réalisé le plus
bel exploit de sa saison les plaisirs
aux à la lutte pour le maintien se sont
imposés à domicile contre drancy l'un
des prétendants à la montée
une victoire acquise sur le fil une ans
dans une ambiance électrique qui
pourrait compter à la fin de la saison
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
avantage de romain russe finit il
épuisera peuvent jubiler lepers et vient
de faire tomber le deuxième du
classement drancy à domicile une joie
décuplée par le scénario du match en
première période plaisir n'arrive pas à
prendre la mesure de son adversaire et
se fait corriger 17 à 3 avec deux essais
concédés
effectivement on prend 17 points mais
c'est surtout dû à nos erreurs on les
met dedans avec nos erreurs et fasse une
belle équipe comme ça c'est sûr qu'on
est sanctionné tout de suite
il a manqué un peu de maîtrise sur cette
première mi temps pour espérer faire
mieux
la première mi temps on la perd
largement et on remet en question dans
les serres larbi le capitaine
les entraîneurs et ça nous a amené un
coup de un coup de jus pour finir ce
match en deuxième période les joueurs
plaisir war reviennent sur la pelouse
métamorphosé arrive à inscrire trois
essais en 40 minutes de jeu
drancy a la balle de match dans les
toutes dernières secondes mais les
visiteurs n'arrivent pas à conclure
plaisir l'emporté sur le fil 24 à 23
nos dernières pénalités et notamment la
dernière bon on s'en sort très bien avec
le poteau le quinze qui récupère qui
fait un en-avant dans l'en-but on
commence on pouvait pas avoir meilleur
scénario effectivement en terme de
réussite
après j'ai envie de vous dire par
rapport à tous les matches qu'on a eu
avant c'est un peu justice
qu'aujourd'hui ça tombe pour nous avec
cette victoire plaisir pointe à la 9e
place du championnat de fédérale 2 avec
7 points d'avancé sur le premier
relégable paris université club
avec cet exploit le staff plaisir on
espère désormais pouvoir terminer la
saison en milieu de tableau
encore un grand bravo à plaisir dans le
championnat de division honneur le sky
rugby n'a pas pu résister aux assauts de
l'entente maisons laffitte saint jean
les poissy leader du championnat les
saint quentinois se sont lourdement
inclinés 41 à 6 ce dimanche après midi
au classement le sky reste 7e du
championnat avec un bilan de 5 victoires
1 nul et huit défaites depuis le début
de la saison
un échelon plus bas dans le championnat
de promotion honneur
montigny-le-bretonneux a également connu
la défaite et il y monte 1 se sont
inclinés ce dimanche 54 à 10 à
l'extérieur sur le terrain du rugby
aulnay club au classement les
saint-quentinois ont raté le coche ils
sont toujours deuxième à neuf points du
leader honni la montée semble compromise
nous allons maintenant parler à foot
ball trap a réussi une très belle
prestation ce week-end et rapide se sont
imposés sur le score fleuve de 3 buts à
0 face à franconville une équipe de bas
de classement avec ses victoires très
pro prend la place de leader à boulogne
billancourt après 13 journées disputées
pour nous parler de cette performance
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président interviewé gayssot ainsi que
toufik ben saada qui est joueur dans
l'équipe 1 senior bonsoir
alors cette victoire est ce qu'elle
était espéré président on était
principalement depuis le début de saison
les garçons font travail ils font ils
font le nécessaire pour atteindre
l'objectif donc ils sont bien partis
pour moi et voilà c'est une cohésion de
groupe un bon boulot du staff avec le
coach hicham et voilà on sent qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va se passer en fait
saison 12 mois moi je l'espère pour le
club pour les garçons pour l'image de la
ville et moi j'ai toute la confiance
envers eux parce que je sais qu'ils vont
le faire parce qu'ils sont dedans
ce que j'ai vu dimanche pour moi il n'y
a pas de pas d'inquiétude
et puis voilà répit la moustache excusez
moi et puis il ya tous fiq
voilà c'est des joueurs qui apportent
leurs plus values
dans ce groupe il ya lui il ya d'autres
joueurs qui sont arrivés en renfort pour
cette année et l'envoie avec l'univers
notamment passé par qu'elle ait un taux
fixe et/ou également exactement ça
donc on voit on voit le niveau ils
apportent leurs plus values avec les
jeunes je vais les laisser développer
mais voilà je suis content en tout cas
3-0 à domicile sous un soleil printanier
c'était une journée un dimanche parfait
finalement toufik oui forcément c'est un
dimanche parfait la victoire la victoire
était et est importante parce qu'on
sortait de faim sur les deux premiers
matches le 2019 on avait deux gros
matches à l'extérieur on avait réussi à
aller chercher de bons résultats nuls et
il savait que on savait qu'il fallait
des bonifié absolument sûr sur les deux
matches qu'on avait à domicile par esi
et et franconville 1 une équipe qui se
bat pour pour pas descendre et voilà on
a réussi à obtenir les deux résultats
qu'on espérait donc forcément c'était
un dimanche parfait qu'est ce qui a
fonctionné dans ce match a trait à peu
près suite non non non à peu près tout
parce que c'est ce que je dis
aujourd'hui on a la meilleure défense du
championnat donc
forcément c'est que on travaille tous
ensemble et voilà on est rentré on est
rentré très très bien dans le match avec
énormément de respect pour notre
adversaire et on a on a su marquer sur
des moments clés parce qu'on a marqué en
tout début de match et en tout début de
deuxième mi temps ce qui leur a mis un
coup au moral et ce qui nous a permis à
près de dérouler tranquillement on voit
le classement est ce qu'il faut
minimiser cette victoire en se disant
que les adversaires jouent le maintien
où justement il faut renforcer les bases
on va dire sur une victoire comme celle
là pour construire la suite de la saison
non on minimise pas un tel résultat
parce que la semaine dernière
y perdre 2 1 contre 100 tours l'aumône à
la 90e minute donc ça serait réducteur
de dire qu on joue une équipe de bas de
classement et donc c'est très simple et
donc l'équipe est faible et que au
dessus enfin il faut juste faire le
travail en fait et le travail a été bien
fait et c'était le plus important je
pense que jouer contre des équipes du
bas de classement à ce moment là c'est
pas forcément
chose aisée parce qu'eux aussi se bat
pour quelque chose
une équipe du milieu de tableau bon elle
joue un peu en roue libre à partir de
trois quatre matches de la fin là pour
l'instant tout le monde tout le monde se
bat donc voilà à domicile il fallait
prendre les points on les a pris sans se
poser trop de questions on continue
notre bonhomme de chemin
président vous êtes d'accord avec retire
nous accorde le coach l'a dit aussi hier
dans les vestiaires à la fin de la
rencontre que il ya encore du chemin il
lui reste encore sept matches de
championnat
et puis on va les prendre un par un et
injuste et que les garçons ils sont
conscients on va prendre le maximum de
points mais en tout cas voilà on va on
va pas lâcher le podium et pour
atteindre l'objectif quoi et ça fait
très longtemps que le club de trappes
attend ça surtout sur la catégorie
senior et franchement ça serait super
extraordinaire que notre équipe senior
racole la compétition r2 montée en l2
puis voilà ça va équilibrer avec nos
jeunes qui sont des gens fiers d'eux et
voilà le club bien structuré le club il
a un cap et voilà moi pour moi cette
saison elle est pour le moment tout est
au vert pour toutes les équipes
et puis voilà sur battant de la fin de
saison pour que ça se bonifie en
résultats et en montée des seniors est
ce qu'on attend ça avec impatience cette
montée du côté de trappes trappe qui a
vécu de nombreuses contre-performances
et bien la saison qui a échoué plusieurs
fois à monter les trois cadres et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut il faut essayer de il
faut essayer de tempérer il faut pas
s'enflammer
non mais de toute façon ça sera pas
notre cas parce que parce que du coup le
club à structurer les choses on a on a
un staff conséquent
des gens qui travaillent très bien avec
voilà il cham miloud épisodes tous les
gens qui sont qui sont autour donc et
puis on a on a ils ont réussi ce beau
mélange entre les anciens les joueurs
d'expérience et et les jeunes qui nous
apporte énormément et on n'a jamais
on sait jamais pris pour d'autres et je
pense pas que ça va commencer qu'on va
commencer maintenant
voilà maintenant je pense qu'ils
venaient de la facilité non non surtout
pas parce que je pense que ça serait ça
sera un échec d'avoir fait si on parle
du pecq aussi on est sur 14 matches sans
défaite donc ça serait dommage de lâcher
si près du but mais l'objectif
l'objectif premier il est de prendre les
matches les uns après les autres et à
partir de trois ou quatre matches delà
de la fin de saison on pourra vraiment
se situer et faire ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est sûr qu'on va pas lâcher
mais on est en étant humble parce que
c'est ce qui fait le travail et c'est ce
qui permet de réussir
dernière question vous allez jouer ce
dimanche contre aunis à l'extérieur une
équipe classée 10e sur 12 équipes
engagées
un pronostic rapidement un pronostic
voila l'exemple type d'une équipe qui
était mal classés qui s'est vachement
renforcé en début d'année qui vient
d'être sont toutes de résultats de
résultat positif parce qu'ils viennent
de gagner 3 1 contre epinay ils viennent
de gagner 3-1 ce week-end contre
naturel indiqué au tableau qui était en
haut de tableau
voilà un nom vrai c'est d'aller chercher
les points lui toi ça serait bien même
chose pour vous même chose avec moi j'ai
confiance aux garçons et il n'y a pas de
souci pour atteindre l'objectif mais moi
je la sens bien parce que je sens le
groupe le groupe il est vraiment une
belle cohésion de groupe comme il l'a
dit toufik les les anciens les jours
d'expérience avec les jeunes ça marche
super bien merci
versez la sur ce plateau bon courage
principe de votre saison vous souhaite
de monter dans la division supérieure
merci beaucoup mais en mai prochain on
continue à parler à football on joue
également ce week-end dans le
championnat de d1 district où il s'est
imposé contre plaisir sur le score de 2
buts 1
pas de souci non plus pour gargenville
contre le ch est né 4 à 2 bio course
effet corrigé 5 à 2 sur la pelouse de
monter son match nul entre sartrouville
et le fc mantois 2 partout mali le roi
est allé chercher la victoire sur le
terrain d'hardricourt enfin à carrière
grésillons s'impose face à morrow pas 3
le championnat est lui toujours dominé
par ouïe devant sartrouville du handball
féminin à présent montigny le bretonneux
et aller chercher une belle victoire sur
le terrain de patronage laïque granville
handball lésigny monteyne sont imposés
28 à 22 ce samedi soir une victoire qui
leur permet de conforter leur septième
place au classement de nationale 2
l'équipe reste à quatre points du podium
après le handball de la course à pied le
38e cross de la sablière s'est déroulée
ce dimanche entre la forêt de meudon et
la forêt de versailles
cette année plus de 950 participants se
sont inscrits au départ des cinq courses
pour la compétition sur le cross long de
11,2 km victoire au sprint de bertrand
ganso du club de verneuil assez la
première féminine et juliette thibault 2
le s renault rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition
on passe maintenant à notre page à jean
bart
[Musique]
on continue par du cyclisme sur piste la
sélection officielle pour les prochains
championnats du monde en pologne fin
février a été dévoilé mercredi dernier
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines coup de
projecteur sur cette équipe de france
des images d'eux patrick jacques de
dixmude la sélection pour les prochains
championnats du monde est tombé la
fédération française a dévoilé les
visages des pistards qui représenteront
la france en pologne du 27 février au 3
mars on retrouvera en vitesse les
expérimentés michael d'almeida grégory
baugé
ils seront associés au jeune sébastien
vigier 21 ans et ryan et là le 20 ans ça
c'était très important pour moi que
cette passation de pouvoir se fasse
sereinement pendant cette olympiade
c'est ce qui se passe ça veut dire que
nos anciens sont encore bien là vous
voyez sont en lice élections beaucoup
d'entre eux peuvent prétendre être
également à tokyo donc c'est très bien
mais en même temps on sent la génération
suivante qui continue à progresser et
qui est particulièrement active pour
gagner ces places dans les sélections
dans cette nouvelle génération
retrouvera notamment chez les féminines
matile de gros 19 ans championne
d'europe du quirinal et et 2018 la
sportive espère maintenant remporter
cette première médaille mondiale chez
les élites conquérante
là l'heure actuelle je me sens vraiment
bien la préparation s'est bien passée
maintenant on peaufine tout ça donc avec
mon entraîneur voilà on n'est plus sûr
de la qualité que de la quantité le
travail a été fait maintenant bas on
verra un peu
comment ça va se passer mais en tout cas
j'espère vraiment performer sur scène
monde l'année dernière lors des
précédents championnats du monde la
france a remporté seulement deux
médailles de bronze aux pays bas la
fédération française on espère le double
à pruszkow en pologne dans cette équipe
de france on retrouvera un certain ryan
et la halle tout juste 20 ans ce pistard
qui a terminé ses études ici à monti le
bretonneux participera sessegon
championnat du monde après ceux d'apple
donne aux pays bas l'année dernière nous
avons eu la chance de le rencontrer
interview nous allons parler sport et de
cyclisme sur piste à mes côtés ryan et
la halle bonjour bonjour comment allez
vous le très bien ou très bien
alors aujourd'hui c'est un jour
particulier pour vous vous avez été
sélectionné pour les championnats du
monde
première action très content on a moins
très content on a tous une participation
en championnat du monde donc voilà c'est
satisfait à deux jets pour en découdre
alors on va revenir sur votre parcours
vous avez 20 ans tout juste vous êtes né
le 21 janvier 1999 à saint martin
d'hères en isère est ici maintenant vous
retrouver ici dans les yvelines
ces sommes j'ai donc je suis né dans en
isère et j'ai débuté ma carrière là-bas
en isère
je pratique le vélo depuis l'âge de 6
ans j'ai commencé la boxe de saint
martin d'hères évidemment du coup et
puis après de fil en aiguille j'ai
évolué jusqu'au pôle de saint-etienne
régional de pôle de saint-etienne
delage a été remarqué pour ma propre
affaire participent à des épreuves sur
piste en sprint
au début j'avais décliné un peu mais
offre et après page et je vais pourquoi
pas j'ai testé j'écoute j'adorais c'est
le mot j'ai adoré j'ai adoré ça et puis
depuis bajeux s'installer là en
septembre 2017 et et on va dire je suis
accro à la piste mêlant et vous êtes
yvelinois c'est ça et qu'est ce qui vous
a donné spécialement envie de faire du
cyclisme est une personne en particulier
ou tout simplement c'est votre
expérience personnelle en montant sur le
vélo n'ont apprécié déjà les expériences
n'ont autant sur l eau et puis voilà
deux
surtout que je le côtoie mais grégory
baugé quelques grandes sur la piste
campus qui ici avec moi donc c'est
quelque chose d'extra de voir quelqu'un
comme ça un grand champion et évidemment
d'autres champions impôts pour l'a pas
cité mais michael d'almeida
quant à la fac et françois pervis
étaient des gens de la piste et du coup
de dieu entre et ça fait toujours
plaisir
même mon expérience personnelle m'a
donné très envie de 2,22 de nous
développer dans cette discipline
et qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
l'équipe de france moi c'est cette
france qui se tiennent mieux en équipe
de france on peut demander à n'importe
qui dans la rue ici on dit parce que
pour retrouver l'équipe de france est
allée le must de chaque discipline c'est
ouais c'est le grave c'est on représente
la france
pour un championnat du monde c'est
quelque chose de mots est ce que vous
êtes dit à un moment donné dans votre
carrière votre jeune carrière que vous
alliez aller en équipe de france
est ce que vous aviez cet espoir là où
je ne sais pas mais j'avais vraiment
cette envie et cet espoir de d'y être et
du coup cette sur le sprint et j'en suis
complètement content comment vous voyez
votre avenir
c'est forcément les jo-2020 quatre
médailles d'or il cessa sur cette piste
ici d'entraînement donc qu'est-ce que
vous connaissez par coeur jean reno
parker on s'entraîne aussi deux fois par
jour donc ce que je fous de grande
beauté à paris chez nous à la maison
donc on se prépare très bien pour ça et
on veut clairement ça va être champion
olympique
clairement faire mon deuil médailles
d'or et deux médailles d'or sur ces jeux
là oui c'est ça merci beaucoup rayonner
l'aller on vous souhaite bon courage
pour ces championnats du monde qui se
dérouleront en pologne et également pour
les jo-2020 tca trou on espère une
médaille d'or pour vous merci minuit et
on referme ce magazine par un
anniversaire le capitaine de la team
europe pendant la ryder cup 2018 au mas
bjorn verte fête aujourd'hui son
anniversaire
né le 18 février 1971 à silkeborg au
danemark le golfeur souffre aujourd'hui
sa 48e bougies il a guidé l'équipe
européenne à la victoire en septembre
dernier face aux américains de tiger
woods au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
encore un très bon anniversaire c'est la
fin cette émission très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]